I'd like to talk about mm-hmm the
beginning yeah of you and I I'll be
interested to see what if your story
matches my story I think that I met you
at the commercial audition for Pepsi one
for Pepsi for Michael Bay the one he
directed well what happened was and when
I were in like room downtown you're in
that Lobby La Center studio right and we
were looking each other do we say I
don't think anyone said hey I'm Bobby
and I'm Eric I think we just were
friendly to each other yeah but we knew
that there was one part yeah and then
they were bit and when you were going
for the same part so you were the last
two right yeah weird their life they had
released one guy who I always felt like
I always felt bad for the guy that was
like thank you so much yeah because I
was that guy plenty - yeah I know you
were [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you and so we look each other
you I did said he would go in and so now
Michael Bay is sitting there with like
four or five guys and they look cool
yeah that well there ya are Co they are
cool right there sitting there their
legs you know they they cross their legs
and sit like this yeah their hairs
perfect her hair is perfect and I swore
to [ __ ] god all I heard was crush
like laughter oh and then when you know
you know you go at this guy he's
probably the best he is and we're gonna
get it but I went in there I did okay
yeah I heard laughter when you went in -
yeah yeah and then they would bring
Erick back in right and back in four and
then you here for laughing yeah and they
would bring him back in and she was like
edible laughs ah it was brutal it was
brutal yeah yeah and then they brought
us in together well don't you remember
we were both sitting there they were
boasting they're out in the lobby or
whatever yeah and at that moment in time
we probably we're talking it's like dude
this is weird like whoever gets it
whatever yeah yeah yeah and then they
pop their head out they're like we'd
like you to both come in right we just
never happens and didn't they just kind
of hire us right there they did yeah
yeah you're gonna be the guy yeah you're
both are gonna be the
then it became when we actually did the
job
go on it was a disaster for me I was in
deep water number one it was a Super
Bowl commercial yeah yeah it was so it's
big yeah yeah it was a spoof on
Goldilocks and the three bears
right and Kim Cattrall was Goldilocks
and and Bobbie and I were the towel boy
towel boy right and now you have to
understand this
and Eric's worked with me a couple of
times on different things it's a I'm a
dis I'm I was young and yeah I don't
know why you're tense
I tell you love the panic that I get
yeah all those things right they're real
this is a reoccurring nightmare you're
not they're not yeah yeah it is I still
talk about it I do too yeah yeah so it's
like I when I get big jobs and a room
big people I panic and I go through the
you know people that are fans of the
podcast know how weird I am and that all
is real yeah it is real so what I've the
nice item ease always told you that it's
misplaced because you are not in those
places by accident you are that
challenge at all thank you you need to
fall back on that every once in a while
except when I'm giving you [ __ ] yes and
that's really nice that you would say
that I'm about to cry that you said
something like that but anyway let's
move on from there yeah let's not go yes
I get to [ __ ] comfortable so do you
remember though how difficult it was for
me to because we're shooting the
commercial and Michael would come over
and say all right is the light thing
gonna go off this time and then the
camera is gonna be on the track right
and it's gonna do this and then we're
gonna do that all right and then he
would look at me and be like alright
you're hilarious just keep doing what
you're doing you Bobby
stay in the [ __ ] light if I can't see
your face you're not gonna be on camera
do you understand that and it just would
berate Bobby yeah and then compliment me
the best thing and then I wasn't
no no now one boy he grabbed my face he
grabbed my he went from behind the
camera Michael Bay grabbed my face and
go to light the light right I mean I
kept looking at Eragon oh this is the
worst but to be fair like why couldn't
you just because I never really I mean
that was like what my third or fourth
job yeah but oh my god so we had to do
this a little comedy comedy thing where
I would peek around the corner and then
Bobby would peek underneath me or I
would take down and then Bobby would
pick her up you know yeah you know this
kind of yeah and you could never get
your face in the light and then do you
remember what else happened when we were
shooting that commercial don't know I'm
not better at about oh yeah I know
Michael Clarke Duncan showed up yeah so
we're having lunch right there's lunch
yeah
and now at this point I'm I just I mean
I'm not out really saying uh bye I'm
sure he's nude I was just this is the
worst I hate it you know and I quit
whatever line and then we're having
lunch and then this out of nowhere a
gigantic gorilla gorilla we can sell it
was because he was in Planet of the Apes
he came in in full full we're not
calling Michael okay my god he would say
this second city this one yeah
Wrigleyville oh yeah yeah I lived there
for two years yeah he came into real
estate when he said that when you said
that Wrigley Field he wasn't that
impressed man but I get one oh yeah
he'll hardly next to I way to pump the
brake so yeah he came in and everyone
Michael like touching his and he made
him like do a cry yeah yellow eyes yeah
thanks
was amazing anyway that commercial
didn't run that much and then but here's
what do you remember this well at the
end of the commercial go on you and I
was standing next to each other
mm-hmm Kim Cattrall walks up to you
would you remember this and says you're
gonna be a very big star she said that
to me yes and what did she say to you
she looked at me said nothing and walked
away things happen with me though No so
you guys have this picture where you're
dressed as mimes where's that from
oh that's where you're sitting on my lap
an IBM commercial knows another I've
been bank robbers yes you guys were like
a duo for a while you guys just ran I
think in the late nineties yeah we ran
there was like 10 guys that booked every
commercial hmm yeah yeah I mean I would
book I mean I literally booked 20 in a
year how many job hit commercial did you
do how many like forever
yep from do your whole career just if
you don't know Joe pica is the he's like
the Steven Spielberg of commercial
director yeah he's you when you book it
Joe pick a job you're gonna go through
hell I mean at least I did but you're
gonna make a shitload of money
yeah and he's he likes finding people
that he likes and can trust and yeah it
works with him and he just keeps casting
him and I was lucky enough I think in
2000 maybe 2000 to book my first America
one with him which was an American
Express commercial and I think between
then and 2007 I did like 60 what do you
were in Italy shooting with them yeah of
a country right yeah it was shooting a
commercial for IBM in front of the
Leaning Tower of Pisa and it the Leaning
Tower of Pisa tumbled crashed to the
ground and the commercial ran exactly
two times on nine nine and nine ten of
what happened at 11:00 Bobby oh yeah
so the that commercial never really
really did much yeah by in retrospect
was a [ __ ] exactly yeah yeah I got to go
to Italy yeah and you I remember one
night you said you had to pick I mean he
was he was nice to you right very nice
yeah but to me it was nice to you too he
kept hiring you that means he likes you
I know but the things he would say
though well did you don't bring those on
at all examples the abuse what that's
what you just said right now it could
have been a spiritual awakening just now
really because in many ways I like to
blame people mm-hmm but I have to look
at my behavior you do and and I have to
I have to look at the things that I say
and then join and do and things I invite
and you know what that's too shady you
my friend
you could be right about that but he did
system crazy [ __ ] yeah like what ching
chong ching chong get on your bar
yeah yeah yeah but I've heard him say he
doesn't discriminate
he doesn't yeah no he says crazy things
about a lot of things yeah and he's the
best in the business and I made a lot of
money and they thank you so much mr.
fitta
yeah he's thank you so much he is really
literally one of the people responsible
for me to be able to be in the position
to even get a job like modern family
because when I would go into auditions
because of working for him consistently
I was you know secure I like I felt
secure and I felt like I had confidence
because I had a few Duckett's in the
bank and I didn't have to go in there
with desperation pouring out of my pores
yeah yeah you're right I mean like he
was like I did one job for him an IBM
job I made three hundred thousand
dollars for one job and this is in 1999
no I didn't make that much on one which
one was that it was the juggernaut with
the spacesuit one Oh with me that was a
huge huge campaign yeah yeah yeah so I
just I'm just grateful for yeah yeah
yeah for all that and even when I was on
that I did the bank wat robber on with
you remember
yeah at the shaved head yeah that was
great I was a great one that's when we
did that I forgot about that one yeah
that's with me little that's the one
you're talking about where he's sitting
on my lap or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah we are I'm wearing a little pork
pie hat
[Music]